about 750
000 Americans will die prematurely this
year because of eating the standard
American diet
on top for today is the Blue Zone
superhero himself Mr Dan buettner so
before World War II we were eating
mostly a whole food plant-based diet
meat consumption America about tripled
between 1880 and 1890 so even if you've
never heard his name before chances are
you have heard the term blue zones blue
zones around the world places where
people are living the longest are drying
up because we are exporting our way of
eating a true Renaissance Man Dan is an
investigative journalist he's a National
Geographic fellow a legit boots on the
ground longevity expert a New York Times
best-selling author many times over and
he's here today his fourth appearance on
the podcast with a gorgeous new book out
called the Blue zones American Kitchen
it's a must-read primer on Healthy
Living it's a cookbook meets road trip
in which he excavates the history of
American Cuisine and food culture and
unearth the original indigenous American
diet which let's just say is very blue
zones
their original way of eating was not
only
a diet of longevity but as we found in
this book
there was culinary genius that has been
lost for the last 10 decades or so he is
the man when it comes to how to live
long how to live happily how to live
well and how to fuel your life with
greater meaning and a sense of purpose
these are real people living in the
world who aren't suffering from heart
disease and diabetes there's something
real here you friend he's a mentor and
an Exemplar of service whose life and
work of positively permanently and quite
unequivocally improved the well-being of
millions so it is with great pleasure
that I share his wisdom with you today
um it's good to see you uh very excited
to have you back this is your fourth
appearance on the show
um
a lot has happened since we last sat
down together a couple books uh you
moved to Miami I mean I guess I'd like
to just start off with like how is life
in Miami like why did you move to Miami
again I joke it's the land you don't
strike me as a Miami guy a land of deep
Tans and Shadow conversations uh no no
well it's it's actually a Blue Zone you
know it's um I live in a very walkable
Community the southern tip of South
Beach I swim in the ocean almost every
day
uh there's great access to good food
it's a easy jump to the Caribbean easy
jump to Europe
I'm 15 minutes away from an airport
makes a lot of sense we have the reason
I the original reason for moving there
is we had three Blue Zone projects there
in Naples
um in Jacksonville and then almost in
Orlando that actually didn't come to
fruition but it just made sense for me
to be there for a number of reasons and
um I got stuck there and and uh it's I
kind of you know some people have a
midlife crisis and you know buy a sports
car or find a mistress I'm moving to
Miami for a while I like it down there
for those reasons there's a great public
pool there's rentable bikes everywhere
you can walk everywhere it's always warm
swimming in the ocean I mean year round
who doesn't like that like it's pretty
fantastic I don't know if I could live
there though you know I joke about the
shadow conversations but actually since
the pandemic there's been an infusion of
New Yorkers and Californians have come
there sure and there's actually a very
emerging high octane group of people a
lot of them involved with technology but
also just a lot my particular group of
people is really into philanthropy and
doing philanthropy right and um you know
you met a few of them at the the YPO
event we saw each other at and
um it's uh it
just about any place in America
you can find
10 or 15 people who you resonate with
and and if you can't find them the
problem's probably not the place it's
probably you and kind of approached
Miami with that same attitude yeah well
I've got some great friends there uh and
the food scene there I think is
fantastic what you know our our mutual
friends Diego and Veronica are doing we
can talk about that as we get into the
new book uh our mutual buddy Marco
Borgia is like there's some great I love
seeing my friends down there and and
visiting so Mark parisky appeal yeah
yeah exactly that whole crew as well
um but but I I am very humored by the
fact that you live in the same building
as Mark Sisson and you've got this
unusual like Bromance with him oh we do
now he's a primal guy he'll tell himself
he eats a steak every day and I'm a
plant-based Guy and um yeah we're uh we
we meet in the gym and and we could not
have more
uh polar opposite ideas on what we ought
to be eating but but um yeah we're we'll
play Pickleball together we're Pals I've
I've known mark for a very long time
I've always gotten along with him fine
and it's always kind of like a jocular
sort of you know reparte with him about
diet philosophy because he is on the
other end of the spectrum but listen the
guys totally fit you know how old is he
now he's 69 he's completely ripped right
yeah I worry about his arteries but uh
you know he's he's got good ABS well
anyway we're here to uh
talk about all things blue zones kind of
expand on what we've talked about in in
Prior
podcasts and the the kind of
um
uh resonant datra is this new gorgeous
incredible book that is coming out
called the Blue zones American Kitchen
which is sort of like in thinking about
this book it's sort of like a buddy Road
Trip movie meets a cookbook from the
perspective of like an archaeological
dig into the history of the American
diet and indigenous cultures like I it's
it defies genres you can't just call it
a cookbook like it's many things it's
historical record it's
um it's sort of a you know a cultural
canvas of a certain slice of American
history that has gone under if not
altogether unreported about our
relationship to food and I don't know
why don't you first like describe the
book and what got you interested in the
subject matter that we're going to talk
about today I describe blue Zone's
American Kitchen as kind of an effusion
between science writing I unpack an idea
in it and National Geographic magazine
will have a condensation of it in the
January issue a National Geographic
photography David McLean I think is the
best photographer National Geographic
he's been your guy forever yeah we've
been working on Blue zones together for
20 years but he has six other cover
stories for National Geographic
and then I learned a long time ago
that
giving people what they want as a
delivery vehicle for your ideas makes a
just the everything a lot easier so I
collected a hundred recipes from around
America that that bring this way of
eating this lost diet of longevity to
life and you know I could have written a
regular book that unpacks the sort of
the science of the diet and the
anthropology that we did to find in the
epidemiology but um you know my last
book The Blue zones kitchen was you know
I never set out to be a a quote unquote
cookbook writer I write for National
Geographic but it was by about a factor
of five my most successful book and it
had 100 recipes people love recipes they
do yes especially if they're original
they uh they don't just want the why
they want the how
yes and I think beautiful picture helps
as well that does right well this book
is is a lot of a lot of uh a lot of how
but it's also the why right so
with all of your experience traveling
all over the world and identifying these
uh you know pockets of humanity that not
only live longer but many of which also
live happier you've kind of turned your
lens on America in the you know
historical record of the blue zones
they're the only Blue Zone in the United
States is
the population of people in Loma Linda
because of their spiritual tradition but
what made you think hey let's look at
America and kind of go behind the scenes
and figure out if there's more of a blue
Zone story here than originally thought
possible
all the time are there are there more
blue zones in the world and there
probably aren't but I started taking a
deep dive into America to look for a
culture of longevity and um
Mormons live slightly longer than other
subcultures in the United States
you look at ZIP codes in Colorado and
you see life expectancy 20 years higher
than certain ZIP codes in Kentucky
um but instead of trying to take a
geographical approach I read about three
years ago a statistic that about 750
000 Americans will die prematurely this
year because of eating the standard
American diet and I got to thinking
there must have been diets in America
here eaten by different subcultures that
more mimicked what we saw in blue zones
so I hired a
researcher from NYU and together we
spent about six months going in the
archives we found 70 or so
anthropological studies and then several
of these dietaries dietary studies
essentially a researcher goes and sits
with a group of families for about two
weeks and records everything they ate
sure enough
for ethnicities who lived well during
the 1900s 1920 were eating almost the
exact same dietary pattern as we saw in
the blue zones so I thought aha now
there is an alternative standard
American diet or diets as it were that
I'd have a light shine on them because
you know
blue zones around the world places where
people are living the longest are
drying up
because we are exporting our way of
eating uh this horrible way of eating
that's largely emerged since the 1970s
and here there are these other four ways
of eating that could not only you know
save America or save several hundred
thousand lives per year but also it
could be something we could be exporting
for the good of the world rather for the
the detriment so you go back into this
historical record right and you kind of
unearth these studies there's this guy
Wilbur Atwater is that his that's right
yes and this is the guy who did he
originally coin the term calorie in the
context of how to look at populations
and dietary patterns he brought the idea
to America and refined it so before uh
Atwater there was no way to tell how
much energy was in your food and he's
the one who more or less discovered that
a carbohydrate has four calories uh per
gram protein S6 and and a fat has nine
and you know with that inside site
you're able to you know call calories
and see which things are could be making
us fat and which Things Are
calorically less less dense but he also
for a precursor of the USDA developed
these dietary studies in America and
started when was this what's that how
long ago was this he started in about
1895 and and he and his colleagues went
to about 1920 and they've been refined
over over the years but he did the first
ones and not just with populations of of
central Europeans and Northern Europeans
he embedded his teams with African
Americans with with uh Latin America
Asian Americans and Native Americans and
uh came out with a very different
picture of the way those people ate than
you know my grandparents for example
were Central and Northern Europeans and
so immersing yourself in these studies
this historical record starts to paint
this very different picture of the
history of of Americans indigenous and
otherwise lies in their relationship to
food and diet
right so when you look at the longest of
people in the world and you do a
meta-analysis in other words
for the original Blue Zone project we
found
155 dietary surveys done over the past
80 years in all five blue zones because
if you want to know what a centenarian
eight to live to be a hundred you have
to know what they were eating when they
were 10 and when they were young adults
in middle age and retired you can't just
ask a centenarian what they've been
eating lately
and what emerges a very clear pattern
whether you're in Asia Europe Latin
America United States they're eating 90
to 100 Whole Food plant-based the five
pillars of every longevity died in the
world
are whole grains greens tubers like
sweet potatoes nuts and beans in fact if
you're eating about a cup of beans a day
it's probably adding about four years to
your life expectancy they are eating
some meat but on average only about five
times per month way less fish and fewer
eggs than you would think no cow's dairy
in blue zones by the way and when
they're drinking it's mostly water about
six glasses a day teas and coffee
so
the filter that we're using to identify
these diets of longevity in America were
the dietary patterns being followed by
Americans and indeed by looking at these
dietary surveys done by Atwater we found
among African Asian Latin and Native
Americans they were essentially eating a
blue zones diet
about a hundred years ago
that's quite a light bulb moment it was
huge because he's a writer a few things
are happening first of all you know
there's these under celebrated
ethnicities that um you know we often
think that they're eating crappy food or
purveyors of crappy food but you know we
largely corrupted the way they were
eating 100 their traditional ways of
eating
um and and morphed it into something
isn't all that healthy uh but the the
their original way of eating was not
only
a diet of longevity but as we found in
this book there was culinary genius that
in many respects is has been lost for
the last 10 decades or so
well let's uh before we kind of dig into
the specifics of those cultural dietary
patterns and habits I think it would be
really instructive to take a 10 000 foot
view of
how our relationship in the United
States how our relationship with food
has changed over the last hundred years
I mean currently we're this incredibly
prosperous Empire for lack of a better
phrase and on many levels and yet we're
so profoundly unhealthy and in the
introduction of the book you do you know
an amazing job of kind of recounting
some statistics that are quite damning
you mentioned 750 000 people die every
year from the standard American diet
um 85 of the 3.7 trillion dollar
Healthcare of health care costs are
spent on treating preventable diseases
that are caused largely by what we eat
and you know the amount of meat sugar
milk cheese processed foods Etc
obviously is the primary culprit and
contributant to all of these things but
walk us through you know sort of a
little bit of like what it was like what
happened and what it's like now
yes so before World War II uh we were
eating mostly a whole food plant-based
diet the meat consumption America about
tripled between 1880 and 1890 largely
because of two things
number one was the ice-cooled
train car which was enabled meat to be
transported over distance because before
that you more or less had to have a
local butcher or you know you've had a
farm and you killed the your family cow
which happened infrequently the other
thing was the assembly line which the
meat packing plants largely in Chicago
invented in fact interestingly Henry
Ford after observing these meat packing
plants Upton Sinclair wrote about them
as well
um uh created the assembly line that
built the model A but um this so
disassembling uh animals very quickly
and then shipping them in cool cards
allowed enough meat to be distributed at
a competitive price so consumption went
up by a factor of three and that was the
Genesis of the factory farm that we know
today the very first seeds but it was
really in about 1970 that our food
system really went to hell and and it
wasn't because of evil forces by the way
before
1970 or so there weren't enough calories
for to feed Americans and there was
really an urgency and and uh American
Enterprise uh jumped into action they
um so it's about then that uh high
fructose corn syrup uh came online and
started to replace
sugars now as a nation we eat far too
much sugar about 140 pounds a year
that's up from 90 pounds in 1900 and
almost half of that sugar is now high
fructose corn syrup what's wrong with
that
well
high fructose corn chip corn syrup
generates about a hundred times more
free radicals than when you eat it
compared to just eating sugar so the
oxidative stress that comes from
consuming high fructose corn syrup uh is
really uh damn it corrodes us from the
inside out but also high fructose corn
syrup tells our liver to take the
calories we just consumed and instead of
using them as energy today to store them
as fat for tomorrow so
um so about triple the amount uh we're
consuming about about triple the amount
of high fructose corn syrup today than
we were uh in the late 1970s
um second problem
the
popular Revenue model for
um
producing meat went from from the
individual farmer to the industrial
um meat
generating
Farms that were filthy that crowded
animals in diseases proliferated the the
uh the the owners of those industrial
Farms had to then shoot the animals up
with hormones and with um antibiotics
creating a much less healthy meat Supply
thirdly uh similarly the the factory
farm came online that was largely due to
Richard Nixon's secretary of agriculture
a guy named Earl butts and again he was
you know the not having enough calories
in America was a cold war issue so Nixon
said we need more calories and Earl
butts created the system that made
corn wheat soybeans and sugar cane the
the main crops in America the sort of
mono crops we hear about and he was very
good at it and the good news is the
price of those calories plummeted the
bad news was that all these cheap
calories just completely washed over the
American public there's about 4
000 calories produced every single day
for every man woman and child in America
and we should only be eating about 2 000
of them or maybe 2500 calories and you
have billions of dollars being spent by
Madison Avenue and these big food
companies encouraging us to eat these
calories
formulating foods that are irresistible
and for most of human history we lived
in this environment of hardship and and
scarcity and now we live in this
environment of overabundance and ease
all these calories in uh in our food
environment the number of fast food
restaurants has about has gone up by
about a factor of five since the 1970s
and 50 of all retail outlets from uh the
place you get your tires changed to the
place you buy your obesity medicine or
your diabetes medicine force you to walk
through a gauntlet of candy bars and and
and sodas and and salty snacks so it's
it's very hard for us to escape these
unhealthy calories right and at what
point do subsidies enter the picture to
you know continue to deflate the costs
of these products which would otherwise
cost more and create some kind of
stability for the farmers
because that seems to be a huge problem
that we can't yeah that goes back to
Franklin Delano Roosevelt the New Deal
and again it started with a a a a great
intentions the family farmer needed help
but it's been corrupted now so that
farmers are paid only to mostly to pay
these these um corn wheat soybeans and
and um and sugar
um there's there's almost no incentive
to grow organic healthy leafy vegetables
and there's no distribution uh chain to
help get it to Market so
um you have this sort of
self-perpetuating system where all the
economic incentives are behind creating
these grains which do three things one
they're the cheap inputs for junk food
number two it's cheap animal feed for
pork and beef and chicken so we have too
much of that meat at artificially low
prices so we tend to overeat these foods
and the third thing it's making these uh
vegetable oils what most of which by the
way are inflammatory inflammation is the
root of every age-related disease they
make that too cheap and to integrate it
into our food system so as a result
we're consuming about triple the added
fats now than we were in the 1970s and
you know inflammation ensues
yeah Meanwhile we're depleting the soil
as a result of these mono crops and as
these conglomerates the factory farms
and the you know the the huge entities
that are reaping the benefits of these
subsidies and are able to you know keep
prices low they can funnel massive
amounts of capital into lobbying groups
to make any kind of
um
uh public benefit regulatory change just
intractable
if um
if we had to pay the true cost of making
a hamburger it would be about forty
dollars the the cost of what it really
costs to grow that grain and then the
externalities all the all the health
care implications and pollution
implications of of a hamburger
um you know if if if there were true
market forces at work the cost of the
food we eat many of the problems would
go away because eating the this junky
food would be too expensive yeah it is a
misalignment of healthy incentives on
some level all the incentives are set up
to create this you know cataclysmic
problem
um
but one thing I'm curious about is
the insurance companies because you'd
think if they're paying out trillions of
dollars you know every year to deal with
the downstream Health implications of
our dietary patterns shouldn't they be
incentivized to help solve this problem
to not have to pay out so much money to
deal with all these chronic diseases
the great Untold secret of of most
insurance companies is they are really
more like your money manager and they
take in premiums and then they pay out
for sickness and then they just sort of
keep a percentage for profit and there's
actually a perverse incentive for
insurance companies uh to ensure people
who have a lot of disease because they
will they have to collect more money and
they therefore their percentage goes up
so there are several great insurance
companies like Kaiser Permanente and
many of the not-for-profit Blue Cross
Blue Shields companies who have a double
bottom line they not only have to manage
to a certain profit but they all their
boards also hold them to a standard of
creating a certain amount of community
well-being or uh lower disease in in
their in their communities but that's a
minority of insurance companies in
America
a big part of of the solution uh from
your perspective is to create
environments in which uh the Healthy
Choice becomes the Easy Choice right on
some level and you know you've said this
many times that if you're if you're
unhealthy or you're obese or overweight
it's probably not your fault the
tectonic plates of of culture are just
driving you towards these choices that
are creating these issues
the solution being to create an
environment in which the healthy choice
is the easier one and you've
accomplished that I think you've you've
got like 49 blue zones project cities at
this point I know you're not I don't
know how involved you are in that
anymore but
um talk a little bit about that ongoing
project yes we're up to 72 cities wow so
the internet needs to get updated
uh so the the I took 20 years to
identify these blue zones and to study
them and I've been back every year since
to these blue zones including this year
in places where people are manifestly
living longer which means not that they
have better genes or the capacity of
their human machine is greater than
yours or mine uh it's just that they're
not getting the the chronic diseases
that foreshorten their lives so they're
not suffering from diabetes and heart
disease and even dementia and you look
at these cultures and you ask well you
know how are they doing it and it's not
because they have you know ritual levels
of discipline it's not because they have
outside sized senses of individual
responsibility they're not a you know
great diets they're not smarter than we
are they simply live their lives and in
fact you know you should see them at a
party I mean you know some of these
places they'll drink all night and uh
um live it up like you know we did when
we were in college
but their moment-to-moment day-to-day
decisions are fractionally better than
ours because their environment is such
that they're subtly nudged into moving
every 20 minutes the cheapest most
accessible and most delicious food we
found
are these simple peasant Foods beans and
Grains and and greens and and they know
how to make them they have time honored
recipes to make them you know taste
great
um loneliness is nearly impossible and
in every one of these blue zones there
is a vocabulary for purpose
so observing this over and over in 2009
I got this idea of manufacturing a Blue
Zone and the idea wasn't to come into
these communities and try to convince
them to eat plant-based or convince them
to move more or socialize more it was
simply to change the nudges and the
defaults at the population levels to set
people up for Success so they to
architect their decisions so they were
unconsciously making better decisions
all day long how do we do that
in each one of our Blue Zone project
cities we have three teams one team is
working with city council to adopt
policies that favor healthy food over
junk food and to limit junk food
marketing to favor The Pedestrian over
the auto the motorists and to favor the
non-smoker over the smoker and we don't
achieve that by coming in telling people
what to do we come in with menus and a
consensus process where each individual
City we take them through each policy
and and ask them to identify which ones
are most
effective in their community and which
ones would be most feasible in their
community so we can usually get 20 or 25
policies working in the five years we're
in that community
secondly we have a Blue Zone
certification program for restaurants
grocery stores workplaces schools and
churches and we're usually pretty good
at getting about a third to half of all
those buildings
Blue Zone certified so when you walk in
them the you're nudged into moving more
the steps are emphasized over the
elevator and the vending machines are
taken out and at the food service
plant-based food is cheaper and more
attractive than the fried junk food and
then finally a third of our team gets
about 15 percent of the adult population
to optimize their home environments and
I talk about how they do that in this
book The Blue Zone Challenge and to
optimize their immediate Social Circle
so we're trying to get people to make
long term changes to their ecosystem so
they can forget about it and just
mindlessly make better micro choices
every day for years at a time and every
single City Rich that we've been in
we've seen the BMI or the obesity rate
drop and we've seen the life
satisfaction rate go up and that's
measured by Gallup and the the incentive
for the cities the city Mana like what
is the pitch to the city manager or the
mayor or are they coming to you like
where are they seeing uh you know the
benefit for you know it's one thing in a
long-term sense like okay everybody
would be better off if we're healthy but
is it a hard sell to get these cities on
board or are they clamoring to come to
you and your organization to figure this
out we've had about 500 cities come and
ask us to Blue Zone their Community
their population and we've done 72 so
most we have to turn away you ask what
the incentives are uh it's not right for
every politician but there are several
Mayors who make it as a priority the
health and well-being of their citizens
uh and for those Mayors this is perfect
there are other cities there you know I
come from Miami where right now the the
focus is sort of building it up as a
technology Hub so it's not really you
know as high on the agenda where where I
am in Miami right now uh but you take
Fort Worth Texas
um uh Betsy price the mayor there she
was she was a mayor this is a city of a
million people her uh you can meet the
you can meet her any week of the year on
Tuesday afternoon she would she was a
she's you know fairly you know sizable
woman but she would put her like her on
and she would bike through the streets
of Fort Worth and and you could you
could meet her now for her
health and well-being was an important
value but the only cities that work are
cities were the private sector and the
public sector work well together so that
means the mayor the city council the
superintendent of schools the police
chief the CEOs of the big
corporations all have to say we want
this we make them sign a pledge that
they will work with us over the next
five years to get it done and then
typically it's the enlightened
insurance companies like it's usually
the Blue Cross Blue Shield plan or the
enlightened Hospital systems like Texas
Health who say you know we can't keep
shoveling money into this big Health
Care problem and expect it to go away
they take them it's usually a few
enlightened CEOs who take the reins and
and make Health a priority rather than
just cleaning up sickness yeah so that's
at the municipal level have you you ever
had conversations at the federal level
like going to Capitol Hill and like sort
of laying out like what you've
accomplished and what can be
accomplished if you could get the
support of the federal government behind
you I was invited once to address the
the
Chiefs of Staff of several of several
congressmen and I know there's
congressmen like like Dean Phillips for
example who sees this as a priority but
you know the the Wheels of Change move
so slowly at the federal level I can
come into a city and affect change very
quickly with the right mayor in the
right city council and the right
business environment I can turn a city
around in five years it would take two
decades for the federal government I
think too yeah but you know if they ever
invited me we actually
um Vivek murti the the current
um Surgeon General great guy uh he's had
me out to Washington and he's looked at
this model uh several times but you know
in his position he doesn't quite have
the the resources to and access to to
implemented at the national level sure I
feel like most people want to eat better
they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table people to join
us in eating more healthy vibrant
plant-based meals and if you're looking
for the perfect holiday gift for a loved
one right now for a limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.rich roll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
um well all right so so we've sort of
talked about the problem we've talked a
little bit about some of the solutions
that you've been active in but let's get
into you know back to the history of the
American diet and dive into what you
discovered like you you go on the road
in this Sprinter van and you travel
around and you meet people but one of
the first phone calls I know you made
was to our mission buddy Jeff Gordon
here right or who are the chefs I got to
talk to like tell me what's going on in
the America in the Unseen America with
respect uh Cuisine that I might be
interested in checking out
yes so there were a few few criteria I
knew I wanted uh Chef steeped in history
who could reproduce the diet that these
ethnicities were eating 100 years ago
that for the most part and I also wanted
delicious food and Jeff who was the New
York Times food writer and then Esquire
food editor for many years he has an
enormous Rolodex and he
um instantly connected me to people like
B.J Dennis who was a goigichi chef down
in in the Carolinas and uh what does
that mean go agichi yes
fascinating subculture of African
Americans the the goal gichi the
occupied mostly the coastal areas of uh
Northern Georgia and the Carolinas and
they were captured and brought over and
enslaved uh largely because of their
ability to grow rice
there's something called the ace Basin
in the Carolinas which by many metrics
is the largest man-made insulation on
Earth bigger than the pyramids it's vast
and you can still see remnants of it
today but a strain of rice was brought
over from Africa it's not the same as
Asian rice and
cultivated by the goligichi people and
because they had this unique know-how it
their enslavers afforded them a certain
level of Freedom so instead of having to
live on the plantation they got to live
in their own houses near these these
rice fields where they had their own
garden
where they connect it with a local
Native Americans and still had the
influences of their European overlords
and they fused this genius uh
um
culinary tradition uh that really gave
rise to what we think of as as uh
southern cooking
um so they brought over Black Eyed Peas
they brought over the Scotch bonnet red
pepper they brought over sesame seeds
which they call Benny seeds they brought
over okra actually you've heard the term
uh gumbo
gumbo is actually the the West African
term for okra
and yeah I didn't know that so all of
these Foods came from West Africa all of
them came from West Africa along with
many you know we know of fritters
because of West Africans several rice
dishes
from West Africa and in the hands of a
gifted Chef like B.J Dennis or Roosevelt
Browning he once cooked for Black
Sabbath
um kind of a cool you know 80 year old
Rasta guy
um they would take black eyed peas and
tomato and garlic and these Scotch
bonnet peppers with a little bit of
olive oil and then ferment these sesame
seeds and the combination and a little
bit of vinegar and the combinations
acidy and spicy and Umami and you take a
bite of this and it there's no meat in
it it's a hundred percent whole
plant-based food you take a bite of it
and you tear you Pride tears of joy it's
wow it's interesting because when I
think of southern cooking the first
thing that comes to mind is everything
is super fried
I I trust that in your journey you
realize that this comes later and the
antecedent to what we now think of is
Southern Cooking with something much
more pristine and closer to its natural
state correct you know there was a there
was a certain inventiveness that comes
out of the austerity that that the only
Foods they could afford
were the collard greens and the beans
and then the corn and squash they
learned from the surrounding Native
American so meat was very rare So it
forced them how to make plant Foods
taste delicious later on when the price
of meat went down
um you know these people were hungry
much of the time and craving calories
and you know meat was always a very rich
source of calories and often associated
with prosperity and wealth and sometimes
power so you know as at the price of
meat came down and ubiquity came down
it's now entered the
um these Cuisines but their original uh
um
manifestations for hundreds of years
before really the 1950s was mostly Whole
Food plant-based and these dietary
studies we were finding that about
85 percent of their dietary intake came
from Whole Food plant-based and when
they were using animal products they'd
use a little bit of lard to fry or
they'd use a piece of pork the size of a
marshmallow yeah to to season a whole
pot of food yeah and you know I mean you
and I agree violently agree that nobody
should be eating meat I think but um
um
the you know if Americans ate the level
of animal products at the goligichi did
for example we probably have a fifth the
rate of heart disease and quarter the
rate of diabetes we're suffering from
right now yeah and you make the decision
with with this with this book that all
the recipes are 100 plant-based even if
aspects of them historically included
small amounts of meat yes because that's
where the genius lies you know there the
it it doesn't you could take
animal fat and sugar and and poured on
cotton balls and fried up it would taste
pretty good but when your inputs are
beans and and greens and and uh and
sesame seeds and the spices around you
uh it takes an incredible amount of
innovation and invention to make that
food taste delicious and it's there we
just forgot about it and uh you know I
spent the past three years trying to
exhume it and bring it to life in this
book so from reading the Atwater studies
and trying to extract from the the
literature where these pockets might be
how do you begin to identify when you're
going on this road trip okay we're going
to go here here and here we're going to
meet these people like how did you piece
all of that together
well Jeff Garnier gave me some some
leads but then I hired a very clever
producer named Karen Foshay who works at
the LA times and I gave her the criteria
and she worked in tandem with us for
about nine months call you know we we
did the web searches it was networking
uh we would find great vegan chefs
and we'd ask them who their role models
were who cook whole food
um in Philadelphia for example there's a
a famous restaurant called veg Rich
Landau runs it and um Rich it turns out
um it was kind of The Godfather of most
of the the plant-based cooking in
Philadelphia and I said who cooks Whole
Food plant-based here
um and he introduced me to the chefs
around Philadelphia incidentally
um
Phil Philadelphia is the birthplace of
American vegetarianism which grew out of
the same sort of
um
permissive atmosphere that the
Abolitionist uh that made Philadelphia
the center of the abolitionists the
temperance movement and the woman's
suffrage movement wow I had no idea I
didn't know that I always thought it was
in New York
no Philadelphia
um um
Robert Graham was uh was one of the
Godfather Robert Graham famously made
guess what kind of cracker
we learned nothing else today Dan now I
know the history of the graham cracker
there he is yeah I am nourished
you know refined processed food it
wasn't originally processed the original
recipe for Graham Cracker very healthy
whole week you should bring that back a
little bit of molasses the original
graham cracker I should have put that in
here actually yes
um but um
no the temperance uh movement in
Philadelphia gave why gave rise to the
vegetarianism and there was a satellite
in New York but but I will argue that
Philadelphia was the The Vortex so the
philosophical strain like in the Venn
diagram between abolitionism and
vegetarianism I'm just trying to think
what is the what is the sensibility like
the political sensibility in which those
worlds kind of overlapped and women's
suffrage Enlightenment Evolution I was
societal evolution
um a sort of liberal mindset that it
pervades to the stand yeah that's that's
cool that's really cool so you identify
Philadelphia
um
I'm interested in the the journey to
Hawaii and what you discovered there the
big island and kind of the cultural
Traditions that emerge from that
experience that is so rich and I think
some of the most interesting food in
America it comes from Hawaii it's a
very rich and ever-evolving fusion of
Japanese
food Filipino Portuguese and native
Hawaiian and um
several of those original strains are
incredibly healthy and have remains so
today so we have a Blue Zone project uh
in the big island of Hawaii so it was
very easy for me to to engage the people
work for that project to help me find
the historian chefs that are still
cooking the original way
but one of the neatest
I think
um by the way findings in Hawaii is that
it turns out that the longest-lived
subculture of anywhere I could find in
the world
was among the
female Chinese immigrants who live in
Hawaii their life expectancy so uh
Chinese Americans living in Hawaii
females life expectancy is 90. so the
number the highest life expectancy of
any country in the world right now is 88
but here these women these Americans are
living longer and the only reason I
can't call it a blue zone is because
it's not
um geographically isolated they're
people among other people but um uh
here's a fascinating culture and we
thought well maybe the first place to
um look at a diet of longevity in Hawaii
is among these
um
old Chinese ladies living right and so
what are they doing or what were they
doing
it's basically they brought their
traditional Chinese cooking which is
heavy in tofu and mushrooms and noodles
and they continue they've continued to
eat it Asian people are off also masters
of greens like if you go to Whole Foods
you might see collard greens or you
might see a kale or spinach Asian people
will frequently know 40 or 50 different
kinds of greens you know the type of
[ __ ] we'd weed whack from our backyard
they'll they'll know how to steam it up
and make a beautiful dish out of it and
um
so Ruth uh I met this 95 year old
um vibrant woman named Ruth Chang who
cook for us and uh she she wore a bright
kelly green dress and full pearls and
earrings and and she cooked a meal that
her mother taught her how to cook 80
years ago and it was mostly stir fry but
she did amazing things with tofu which I
think is one of the best longevity Foods
out there but what is it about these
Chinese women being in Hawaii that
created this special sauce right like
there's Chinese women living in China
how come their their life expectancy is
extended in Hawaii versus their native
land
they continue to Garden
number one number two they they have
maintained their their food traditions
and cooking the same way and number
three they probably benefit from the
public health system they get in America
that they probably didn't have in China
so they're not suffering from the
infectious diseases and they have access
to a good hospital system there also the
Blue Cross Blue Shield plan there in
Hawaii is one of the best in the country
um you went down into the Waipio Valley
oh that's amazing yeah the photos from
that are unbelievable and there's a guy
that you met that goes in he's still
cultivating the land in the traditional
way yes Taro the Taro is the um the
staple food of traditional wines it goes
back about a thousand years and it was
probably two-thirds of their kill Arc
intake and and um purple sweet potato
sort of thing right yeah they can be
prayer to be prepared a number of ways
most famously it's it's sort of beaten
into a paste and then fermented to to
make this
yeah yeah and uh that's how it's mostly
still I don't find it very delicious but
there's lots of other ways to prepare it
interestingly when um the first
uh settlers James Cook landed on Hawaii
and observed the the native Hawaiians he
observed that they were fit
healthy and they had great teeth
and now in Hawaii thinks largely I
believe to the importation of the
standard American diet the Hawaiians are
the least healthy people ethnicities in
in Hawaii and
um
if they I think paid more attention
and celebrated their traditional diet I
think a lot of those problems would go
away um
there's something really special about
the Waipio Valley like it's protected
right you can't not everyone can just go
down there like they keep it preserved
it was wasn't it the original like land
of of the king yes yeah and I think they
still sort of hold domain over who can
go down there and you can't so if
somebody's planting crops down there
that's a special situation yes we got
permission from the Shafta or the
landowner to let us to let us in the
place looks like Jurassic Park yeah it's
unbelievable yeah the giant Ferns and
cacao trees and papaya and it's rioting
vegetation and around you on all sides
this uh the the valley walls rocket out
of the out of the
um out of the valley and go up several
thousand feet you can see two or three
waterfalls and then it all comes out at
the sea
um yeah it's one of the few places left
on Earth where it's preserved pretty
much the way it was a thousand years ago
they will let you go down
um to like the front of it the the
coastal area you can go down and get a
taste of it but all the land
um as you go back in the valley is owned
by
um native Hawaiians and they're very
protective of oh man
what is the landscape of Chinese or or
more broadly Asian Americans look like
on the mainland of the United States
like you have these women in Hawaii who
are outliving most people what about you
know when you get back to
the 48 yes
well it's you know among Asians it's
hard to uh to separate out their life
expectancy over compared to the rest of
the United States but our mission was to
find
um Asian Americans who were cooking the
way their grandparents and Great Grandpa
parents were
um so in uh Minneapolis we
uh we found this Hmong lady who um
about 200 yards from a Target parking
lot she and her relatives had bought
three acres of land in this tree Grove
and cleared the land and is growing
bitter melon and um
um watermelons and sweet potatoes and
pretty much the foods that she grew up
with and still cooking the way her
ancestors were we found cambodians here
in Los Angeles a group of Cambodian
women who survived the genocide there
and they meet at least once a week and
cook together as a way to bond and build
um
and build community or keep their
Community together
um in New Orleans we met a
um an Indian family
um Asian Indian family who has one of
the most popular recipes in in uh New
Orleans and they created some of their
recipes but in all cases
um they're the best recipes were 100
Whole Food plant-based mmm
what did you learn about the native uh
indigenous Native American diet we've
all heard about Maize and you know what
corn used to be used to look like Etc
um but what's the you know kind of the
truth there and I'm sure you know I know
that you you know met with a bunch of
people yes
so my French obviously it would be
different per region yes so up where I
originate in Minnesota
um they were eating a certain amount of
wild game but while game wasn't always
available so
um wild rice which is actually not a
rice it's a it's a grass seed
several roots and ramps
um in the East so so my friend Sean
Sherman uh who just won a the James
Beard chef of the Year award
um he has been focusing on decolonizing
uh Native American food
pork and beef and chicken and sugar were
never part of the Native American diet
so he's bringing that back he's
contributed several recipes to this book
um in Plymouth Rock we cooked with a
modern day Pilgrim and a direct
descendant of the Wampanoag uh people
Native Americans that
um welcomed and
treated the pilgrims to the very first
Thanksgiving
and
it turns out that we have this
incredibly corrupted idea of what was
served at thing what a Thanksgiving
dinner really looked like the original
Thanksgiving dinner was no evidence
there was any turkey at all at the
original Thanksgiving dinner is there
evidence that there was an original
Thanksgiving dinner there is that
apocryphal or you know there's sort of a
whitewashing of you know that yeah
tragic history
yeah so you know the the
um the pilgrims arrived and the the they
arrived with some Provisions but they
didn't know how to really grow food and
this new land and
um about 50 of them died within the
first few months and these wampanoags
were sort of observing them and took
pity on them and uh
the Thanksgiving was probably more of a
diplomatic Summit than it was some great
celebration of making it through the
summer as we're often heard there was
food there
um there was you know some suggestion
there were oysters there and and corn
um and maybe some foul but they don't
say exactly what kind of foul but there
was no butter there was no flour so
there's no pumpkin pie there was no
stuffing there was no indication of this
turkey
um
the
um Paula Marco who was the the historian
who the food historian who was helping
us recreate this um original
Thanksgiving
um pointed out to us that
um they were probably eating the foods
available to the wampanoags which was
uh corn beans squash probably made into
a meal like succotash
dry blueberries maple syrup uh probably
a type of corn tamale
hazelnuts which were used as sort of a
soup thickener and that was probably
what the original Thanksgiving look like
and the the pilgrims at that time they
didn't have livestock or they weren't
domesticating animals first this was
resources yeah yeah it was pre
um before more animals came but yeah
that first year and how does that uh
diet more for change as you move across
different parts of the country did you
kind of go into a variety of indigenous
Native American cultures and Cuisines
yes farther farther south
um on the south
eastern part of the United States it it
the cuisine starts to resemble Latin
American
um you know corn beans and squash uh
very ubiquitous in the Southeast
um
we had a a Native American Chef uh
re-envisioned
um Boston baked beans made from Beans
and just simply a little bit of maple
syrup he created a corn mash for us that
had cranberries and uh he made a nut
milk out of hazelnuts so it was creamy
and delicious and it sort of a
re-envisioning of what a breakfast might
look like
inspired by uh Native American
influences
do any of the healthy historic diets
that date back to this period uh emanate
from any northern European cultures or
Traditions or did the Europeans just
come over to America and kind of ruin it
for everybody
you know I don't like to say ruin it but
my ancestors from Central Europe and
Northern Europe they brought their pigs
and their cows and their chickens and
their pickles and
um in an environment where you're
working 14 hours a day you know you can
handle those those Rich calories and the
way it was raised was way healthier than
it was today but these the food pattern
that mimics the diets of longevity quite
honestly
um happened among cultures where there
was not a lot of money
and because that absence of of money it
drove inventiveness and Innovation and
quite honestly delicious food and now
we're at a time in history where
coincidentally that delicious food is
what we need to start addressing the
health care problems and the fact that
72 percent of us are obese or overweight
yeah and what is the what is the you
know the on-ramp for that because that's
a you know a a Sticky Wicket that on
some level is almost more challenging
than blue zoning a city like changing
people's dietary Health patterns when we
have this desire appetite or proclivity
for all these foods that are making us
unhealthy I'll tell you a story
Albert Lea Minnesota was our first Blue
Zone City
and this is a meat packing plant and
their you know definition of vegetables
were the orange flecks and hamburger
helper they didn't they didn't know what
vegetables was and I had a great advisor
to that project the woman who
popularized the Mediterranean diet name
Antonio tricopullo and I asked I said
how do I get a Minnesota Town meat
packing plant tone eating more
vegetables
and we were sitting at a table in a
career Greece filled with these
beautiful plant-based foods and she
closed her eyes for a minute she opened
up and she looked at me and she said
feed them
so when I I collected what I thought was
the most delicious recipe on it it's an
IT Korean stew with black eyed peas and
tomatoes and garlic and red peppers and
it's Umami and meaty and delicious even
though there's no meat in it and um I've
tasted it yeah this is your go-to it is
in the morning for breakfast actually
but I invited the entire city to dinner
and in two huge witches cauldrons I made
this a Korean longevity stew for them I
had a chef with me helping me do it I
demonstrated how to make it I printed
out the recipes
and then I invited them all come eat and
I remember sweat dripping down the side
of my face because I was so afraid
they'd take one bite of this and spit it
out they not only ate every last drop I
still have this visceral memory of a guy
with his arm in The Cauldron all the way
down to his armpit with a tablespoon
getting the last little bit out of it
but I had them taste that food once
people taste it and know how delicious
it is it is then you give them the
skills to make it themselves and they
maybe need a little bit of equipment in
their kitchen
um you don't have to convince them it's
good for the climate you don't have to
convince them it's good for animal
cruelty or it's good for their health
that's where the tire hits the road I
don't believe you we're going to get
anywhere by incenting people or
educating people or breaking our fingers
at them and saying you know you're a bad
person because you don't have the
responsibility to eat healthy prepared
forget that we are set up for failure in
this country when we go out into the
food environment 97 out of 100 choices
are bad choices it's not going to change
until we first of all make some of those
choices healthier so that they can be
unconscious and easier and secondly
provide people an opportunity to taste
wonderful Whole Food plant-based and
give them the skills to cook it Hickory
and stew is is your We are the world
yeah it is throwing a massive concert
you know the O2 Arena in London and
serving everybody icarian stew this is
how we're going to solve the problem
yeah believe me it'll work better than
most of the stuff we tried I I dive I'm
with you brother you look at diets you
know the the recidivism curves that you
start the best diet and I've done the
research you start with a hundred people
today
in three months
you lose 10 percent of them in nine
months you lose 90 percent of them and
within two years you lose 97 of them
so yet every year we get back on the the
sisyphean treadmill and start a diet and
think that we're going to burn off the
calories we ate during the holidays and
by about January 20th 75 of people are
no longer on that diet it sells a lot of
books it sells programs it sells this
kind of crappy food plans often but it's
not doing anybody it's just we keep
beating the dead horse of diet expecting
a different outcome and it's never going
to happen um
so with that I mean this is a weird
combination of pessimism and optimism on
the one hand the optimism that if you
can expose people to these foods and the
food is delicious they will gravitate
towards that and that will lead them on
a journey towards healthier choices
butting up against the reality of you
know the Monumental sort of problem that
we're facing to overcome what ails us
yeah so I've my daytime job since 2010
has been creating these Blue Zone
project cities which have set out and
successfully I might add change the
defaults of make the food environment
healthy in these cities I work with so
that's sort of the top-down approach and
these Blue Zone kitchen books are my
bottom-up Approach of and
um you just like endings mitigating
smoking problem it's there's is not one
answer it's the perfect storm that comes
together when you create the economic
environment the the
um uh education and then the policy
environment where you're denormalizing
the bad behavior you're making it
cheaper to do the good behavior and
you're showing people in this case that
it it's not only cheaper but it could be
more delicious
back to the road trip you're cruising
around you can't uh you can't you know
write this book without delving deep
into into Latin American culture like
when we're talking about America it's
you know it's many diaspora here and
it's the Confluence of all these
different cultural influences but of
course you know the Latin American
influence and the history of of that
Cuisine uh is is super important to this
so talk about like how that fit in and
what you discovered on that part of the
exploration mainly this is a question to
set set you up to talk about our friends
Diego and Veronica
well I met them in Miami because of you
and they have the hottest restaurant in
Miami called love life Cafe everybody
who passes through Miami has to go to
this restaurant it's my favorite they're
in addition to being just beautiful
people uh Diego is an absolute
Mastermind wizard in the kitchen and
what he's able to you know concoct is
just magical he's a genius and um his uh
his plant-based Burger won the the
veggie burger of the year I just had
dinner with them on Saturday night and
I'm having dinner with them this morning
they're featured in this book and I I
took I took photos of it to them and I
was like I don't know if you have this
book yet or like if you've seen this but
you know Dan's coming in I just want to
show you this oh yeah I'm glad you did
it so I saw it I just got the book this
week so I wasn't able to show it to them
um but Diego's and Veronica are great
examples of of people who are committed
to plant-based very rooted in their food
tradition in case of Diego it's um
Venezuela in the case of Veronica It's
Brazil and they've taken their
traditional foods and uh rifted off of
them but stayed in the plant-based uh
Lane and their love life Cafe you you go
in there at any given day you see be
suited people you see hipsters the
yoginis uh the mayor of Miami is often
seen there so it's just proof that um
you can take these these simple foods
with some ingeniousness and and appeal
to all Americans
um
and uh I met another fabulous Chef in uh
Houston Texas name
um Adam Medrano
uh he was uh he became a chef at about
age 60. uh he comes from you know Texas
used to be part of Mexico
uh Tejas sure and um Texas is famous for
Tex-Mex food which we tend to think of
you know steak fajitas or slathering
cheese all over
um uh burrito but the
um uh Adan Medrano had found the
original ingredients that made Texas
Mexican foods and it's not steak it's
not cheese it's things like walnuts and
pecans and amaranth and mole moles are
these wonderful Rich sauces made with a
variety of different Chili Peppers and
tortillas and nopales which are these um
Cactus paddles that are stripped of
their thorns and then fried and once
again it's this
um fantastically inventive food rooted
in what people really ate there 100
years ago that he's bringing back and he
shared several of his recipes uh for the
book as well yeah those are the ones I'm
most excited about but what was what was
something that that surprised you I'm
sure you go into this thinking you have
some sense of what you're going to
discover and where this journey is going
to lead you but on some level you must
have been surprised to discover X Y or Z
I was surprised to discover that
there are so many vegans among African
Americans there are more percentage-wise
there are more vegans among
African-Americans than there are
um the other races wow
um something like twice as many and and
the inventiveness of uh African-American
chefs throughout and Ashland North
Carolina the Benny Seed restaurant is
all run by African Americans and uh
Matthew Rayford
um the galagichi's I mentioned
[Music]
um
that was that's probably that's pretty
cool I'm about to have uh this woman
Chef Babette here you heard of her
she's unbelievable she uh she has a
restaurant uh uh African-American woman
she's got a plant-based restaurant in
Compton
um and I think she's
like 72 and just unbelievably fit and
vital I had never heard of her and I
went to the mercy for animals like Gala
party or whatever and they gave her an
award and they showed this video of kind
of like the work that she does and I was
just captivated by her and like what
she's doing in her community so I'm
excited to talk to her and I'm sure
there's tons of people like that out
there the people who are in
African-Americans who are in touch with
their roots are invariably interested in
in plant-based food it really wasn't
until about 1920 that the the the the
African Americans from the rural South
started moving North to the
industrialized North where there were
more jobs places like Chicago and
Minneapolis and Detroit
and what happens then is they no longer
have their Gardens
and their diet starts to change in a
hurry and it gets more aggregated in
restaurants where there's more there's
less vegetables there's a little bit
more cash more food gets fried you know
this fried chicken and uh everything
cooked in this now ubiquitous and cheap
fat uh and you know we often look at
soul food as an example of unbelievably
unhealthy food but it has its roots in
unbelievably healthy food yeah when you
were meeting all of these people and
photographing them preparing food and
interviewing them for this book I assume
that you recorded all of this in audio
Yeah we met before you went on this road
trip and I was like this is a podcast
series you need to like record all of
these interviews and you're sitting on
top of a gold mine because this is a
beautiful
historic record of traditions that are
in Jeopardy of of being lost or
forgotten
yeah what comes natural to you rich is
not natural me I'm a writer you're going
to talk to them anyway you might as well
have a little thing and hit record I
actually bought the uh machine that you
told me to buy and I brought it for the
first three three interviews and then I
forgot about it well here's the thing
what so
yeah so I like to be participatory so
you know a lot of these chefs have
become my friends or were my friends and
so I would arrive and I don't don't try
to make them an anthropological subject
you know I try to hang out with them and
I cook with them and find out about
their lives and we go walk their land
and um
um I sit down and eat with them and yes
when I have I I don't sit down like you
and I are sitting right now and
interview them as much as I can type as
fast as you can talk and uh I T I have
probably 200 pages of notes that you
know I just silently sort of type away
as people talk and distilled it down but
you know maybe maybe it's a follow-up
project you know I know the best chefs
there and I could easily you know go
back and visit them right and pursue
this idea and and um but my you know my
muscle so to speak my journalistic
muscle is with the written word not so
much the spoken word yeah I get it so
what is of of all of these chefs that
you visited with and all the cuisine
that you enjoyed where's the where are
the Hidden Gem restaurants the off the
beaten path you know Jeff Gordon here
approved uh spots that you were lucky
enough to dine at that we should all
know about
Asheville North Carolina there's a place
called El Gallo uh run by Luis Martinez
uh originally I believe from El Salvador
and he he is the one one of these guys
who
um started with austerity and that
inspired this incredible inventiveness
um
I think here join us boy I think one of
the most inventive I covered gelinus
it's a a restaurant here in uh in Abba
Kenny in Venice Beach it's a little bit
on the expensive side but yeah it's a
fancy place pure pure genius love life
we talked about that veg we talked about
that
um
yeah those are some of the there's a
place in Minneapolis called Dao foods
which is a place you you know go buy
herbs or you know tinctures and so forth
and they have just one uh little counter
and maybe
10 tables uh but they do the best
macrobiotic food I've ever tasted this
is more kind of rooted in the Buddhist
yeah slash hippie tradition yeah
um I'd highly recommend that when you're
in La other than Jelena what are the
other places that you like to eat or you
just you just cook up your own icaria
stew
at home no I well you know Ellie I you
know I used to lived here for many years
and
um
I go to Crossroads all the time or
Gracias Madre
um but most of the time we're cooking at
home yeah so that's the secret yeah not
eating out too much
um you know I I'd actually like to talk
about a couple restaurants but I forgot
the names can I you want to look them up
yeah yeah sure
about an age that made the best
restaurant in fact my favorite
restaurant in the whole
my whole trip
I had
this picture was taken
three of 200 yards from a Target parking
lot that's nuts yeah
this was in LA
the m-a-y-e center these are I don't
even know that place it's amazing wow
these women are phenomenal and they they
cook almost to the D Cambodian Foods
they get together once a week that would
be a cool road trip so here it is
Good Vibes restaurant in Long Beach
and it's run by a mother-son team their
name is Kim and Viet Farm Kim
was a refugee and you know she was one
of the last people to escape Vietnam
after the Vietnam War and
is ever thankful to America
and they were the most amazingly
inventive they they had a salad I
remember that was made from fresh
cherries on top of a plant-based feta
garnish with flowers you'd never think
that these three wildly inventive
ingredients would come together to
create pure magic but that was just one
of the many Fantastic dishes they did
and you know a cheap place to eat easy
to park too I feel like there should be
some sort of Zagat guide for all of
these amazing restaurants for you know
people who are traveling across the
country or dropping in on a city that
they're not familiar with and are are
looking for these hidden gems you know I
was able to capture about 50 chefs or
for the Blue Zone American kitchen but
there are several hundred I'm sure
they're not that plentiful you know it's
it is it it is the
um is as you point out it's a it's a gem
um but they're out there and if if you
look you can find them right not
everybody can get Jeff Gordon air on
speed dog I mean listen I'm going to
Orlando like where do I need to eat you
know and he'll just he'll give you 10
recommendations off the top of his head
um all right
well listen Dan it's one thing to have
all of these recipes and they're
beautifully photographed and they're
amazing and nutritious and they're these
amazing personal stories behind all of
them but I just want the food
just can't you create a food company
where you can just send me the stuff
already made
how's that how's that for teeing you up
yeah
that was like a softball pitch that
stopped over home plate yeah like so
transparent so thanks for teeing that up
yes uh I've teamed up with a a team that
is knows exactly how to get food into
grocery stores and we're creating the
blue zones kitchen uh which is a food
company that
is creating dishes inspired by these
longevity longevity recipes around the
world and around America with a maniacal
focus on deliciousness because at the
end of the day if you can't make this
food taste delicious people aren't going
to eat it and I know now for having
spent the better part of five years
traveling around the world picking the
absolute best best recipes I can curate
a dozen or so that I think people like
whether they live in Oklahoma or Venice
Beach or Manhattan and uh make them by
the way the inputs are all cheap so you
can make this food inexpensively so
everybody can afford it and our first
food should be out early 2023. that's
pretty exciting that's no small endeavor
no it's a big Endeavor actually but but
um you know we were able to
um raise enough money to hire
professionals so it's it's not my
day-to-day job we have a great CEO named
Scott Marcus who's
um comes from the from Craft actually
and uh is atoning for his sins over at
craft and it is now dedicated to making
healthy food available to everybody
the hidden story in the narrative around
Dan buettner that I think is under
addressed is a story of Serial
entrepreneurship like you're the humble
investigative journalist yes I write
these books I go on these travels I talk
to people but along the way you have
these ideas for businesses that
um germinate out of the work that you're
doing and have become unbelievably
successful like the cities project and
you know now this like it's interesting
like you're very dynamic in how you
approach these problems and these
Solutions and how you kind of
communicate and and share and then
generate like extremely successful
viable businesses out of them at the
same time
uh yeah but I would say I'm different
than an entrepreneur in that they all
begin with enthusiasms and Curiosities I
I don't I didn't set off writing blue
zones because I wanted to create a food
company or even make American cities
healthier it started because I was
interested in this idea of reverse
engineering longevity and it just seemed
incredibly cool that if I could identify
places around the world where people are
living the longest and use some
established scientific techniques to
find out their common denominators I I
could find a a
a de facto secret to longevity and I
didn't think beyond that and it actually
took me three years just to find the
original blue zones but then
you know after writing the blue zones it
was a big successful book and I was in
uh you know I I was an Oprah and Good
Morning America and the Today's Show on
CNN and I'd sit in these green rooms
before going on and there's all these
other
you know diet gurus in there that had
whatever diet is your you know and
they're all pretty nice people but I
thought to myself well actually what I
found I know it works it's not just hype
these are real people living in the
world who aren't suffering from heart
disease and diabetes there's something
real here and then I got the idea well
maybe you can manufacture
this in America and our first Blue Zone
City you know I got funding from AARP
you know made almost no money it would
you know if I were making money I would
have probably set up something else but
I basically took all the money I raised
and and plowed it into hiring experts
who could help me realize this vision
and even then I didn't set out to to uh
start a business uh a guy named Ben Lidl
who was CEO of a huge health care
company he had 3 500 employees
he wanted to he he read about this and
he was tired of Telehealth which didn't
seem to be produced in a long-term
changes even though it was a billion a
half dollar business he flew out and he
said you know I wouldn't even take his
call
and after not taking his call he and his
four lieutenants get in the corporate
Jet and fly out to Minneapolis and I
have like two employees and he walks in
the door and I well I'm going to meet
him now and we talked for a half hour
and he's the one who talked me into
doing these Blue Zone City projects so
the point being it's not like well Dan
bunner wants to set out to make a
million dollars it's the best
entrepreneurs are are trying to solve a
problem and you're very clear on the
problem and you have ideas around the
solution that's right that's right and
it's and the and the fuel is curiosity
and and wanting to see wanting to see
what I discovered
put into action and work that's what's
cool
and you have the luxury of having a
friend and somewhat of a mentor I
suppose in in John Mackey who's one of
the great you know entrepreneurial
success stories of of Our Generation
John Mackey's done more to put
vegetables on people's plates than
anybody in organic vegetables and
anybody in the history of the world
you know one of the great great
businessman entrepreneurs of of our
country a conscious capitalists great
hiker by the way and uh he loves to hike
so what have you learned from him
through that relationship hire good
people probably the biggest and most
important thing
um have a
strong unwavering vision and only invite
people on your team who share that
vision
I've also learned
you know he's brilliant in that even
though he was CEO of Whole Foods he
somehow found a way to take about eight
trips a year where he'd take off for a
week and he'd go sail around the Bahamas
or he I'm on the British Virgin Islands
or hike the Appalachian Trail or take 15
disparate but interesting people to
Slovenia and for a week and they were
philosophers and people from business
and people who've excelled at Sports and
people from
um you know who own record companies and
he these great hikes he would learn from
all them and a byproduct he
cross-pollinated his friends so he
created this sort of virtual community
around him
and um you know the big thing I learned
is yes it's cool to build a big business
but you also want to excel at the art of
life and excited the art of life is
doing something else once in a while uh
curating a cool Social Circle and being
generous with those people and yeah John
is a paragon of that yeah he seems like
an expert in that
um is the Slovenia trip where you met my
childhood next to our neighbor yes
I thought that story
yeah so Tonya pankoff uh like reached
out to me I don't know a handful of
years ago I think through Facebook was
like hey I'm friends with John Mackey
and this is a person that I hadn't
spoken to nor heard from since I was a
young child in this home that I grew up
in she literally lived right behind us
and she was friends with my sister and I
guess she became like an investment
banker and somehow was in business with
John at some point and fell into that
Circle yeah she was an analyst and uh
for the the grocery industry in the food
industry and Investment Banking and
I find what I found myself just a couple
weeks ago walking with her all day long
and she was just downloading Investment
Banking to me and and investment and I
was telling her about longevity and and
food and so forth one of these great
conversations that goes on for hours you
don't even realize you've hiked 15 miles
but at some point I brought your name up
and she looks at me and she goes He
ritual he was my next door neighbor and
I go really and I go what was he like as
a kid and she said he was a total nerd I
was a Superman yeah which is funny
because I look at you as like the
Paragon of hypnas you're at the very
white hot core of La hypnos in in my
view she knew me in my headgear days and
eyepatch days
um and she was really good friends with
my sister I mean this is when we were
like in elementary school like I
remember her and the story that I always
tell is that I used to be a chronic
Sleepwalker and I would go out like one
time I went sleep walking out of my
house and in the middle of a
thunderstorm and walked like two blocks
away before I woke up and my parents
found me you know I was the kid who
would open up the the dresser drawer and
like urinate in it like we were at a
motel hotel somewhere on a road trip
family vacation Nation where those
little motels that are built around a
pool you know one story places and I
ended up sleepwalking and going into
another open hotel room where people
were asleep in there but the point being
that on one occasion I I woke up in the
middle then I didn't wake up I slept
walk in the middle of the night and I
went over to Tonya pankoff's house and I
knocked on the door and her parents
answered the door and and and I
responded by demanding that they
returned the meat that they had stolen
from us in my sleep and my sister and my
parents still like tell that story like
it's so embarrassing of course now I
wouldn't be demanding me yeah
but yeah I still remember like that I
must have been like nine years old or
something at the time but it's so weird
that somebody from my childhood has has
you know found her way into this you
know circle of friends now it's crazy
but it is cool how John has curated that
and I think that dovetails nice nicely
into the last thing that I want to talk
about which is this idea of the art of
living and this is something I've been
spending a lot of time thinking about
I've spent the last several years like
trying to build this thing up and along
the way you know have experienced
success beyond anything that I ever
imagined but there's been sacrifices and
some of those sacrifices have come in
the form of you know friendships that
I've lost touch with and as I get older
like I turn 56 next week like I'm very
mindful of the meaning of those
friendships and how important they are
and I think there is something that is
maybe even more particular to men as
they age in in how they they kind of
lose touch with their friends and their
circle of friends tends to be smaller
and you know I I I am much more aware of
how important it is to nurture those
friendships you know from the past like
my college buddies and things like that
you know we're not guaranteed a tomorrow
and you know life is short and it is
those experiences that
you inevitably look back upon and never
regret
it really yeah we you know the average
American works over about 45 hours a
week it's too much of our Waking Life
you know EB white has this great EB
white wrote Charlotte's Webb and yeah a
number of other great books but New
Yorker writer be wrote when you wake up
every morning trying to change the world
you don't know if you should be trying
to savor it or save it and it makes it
hard for you to plan your day but
um I become obsessed lately I you know
I'm over 60 now and obsessed with this
idea of of the art of life and finding
that sweet spot between doing something
that's relevant something that gives an
outlet for your particular purpose but
also
uh enjoying life and it takes an
enormous conscious effort to pull
yourself away from work and getting
sucked down these rabbit holes of
busyness and uh I found two things that
have really helped with that number one
very conscious about living in a
walkable environment with easy access to
Recreation nature so the places I live
um are all have that because when I walk
outside my house I'm bumping into people
and it's just so easy to swim or to go
biking much harder to do if you live in
an American suburb second thing this
past summer I I organized I have a place
on a lake called Church Pine I organized
what I call the church Pine Summit and I
invited a nine of guys about my age who
are also about the same light place in
life they've they've achieved a lot but
they're trying to figure out their next
chapter so had Robert Stevens who
started Geek Squad and Brian wansink who
wrote big best seller
um about food and Bart Foster helped
come
facilitated but what really worked and
anybody can do this
um we got together for three days and it
happened to be at a big cabin but it
could be anywhere and during the day
every one of us got an hour to talk
about what we were excited about or what
our next chapter what our next chapter
could look like and we had the input of
the other eight guys you know who have
you know collectively 400 years of
experience to help
um inform that and you know it's these
aren't things you can learn from a book
but we learn from each other uh in the
mornings we you know canoed or hiked or
biked or played pickleball and then at
night we had these um Jeffersonian
dinners which are single themed dinners
there's no sort of Chatty Small Talk
among the uh participants but we all
have one Community around one theme and
it was a theme uh related to this art of
of living and all of us walked away
absolutely on fire and uh with a much
better focus on what the next chapter
looks like for us and and I I couldn't
recommend it Highway yeah so what was
your Epiphany on the next chapter or is
that what you're already doing now
I'm mostly doing it but mostly it was
this food company and I'm I'm putting
more effort into this blue zones kitchen
food company I realize I love food I
love exploration
um most of my social connectivity the
these days happens around a meal so it's
an easy connection between you know this
this company but also it's it activates
my sense of purpose in a in a very
tangible way I love to see taking what
I've learned in these blue zones and
putting it to work in America and I
think right now you know my stage of the
game this is how I can make the biggest
contribution yeah and you can go home to
Miami and you got a neighbor in your
building who knows a few things about
how to build a successful food company
yeah right
uh but on the on the subject of the art
of living like now you have this
opportunity to kind of teach it if I
didn't of uh our mutual friend chip
Conley and his modern Elder Academy yes
I'm gonna go down and and teach there
are you doing it down in down in Baja
Santos oh cool yeah and Baja yes in
March oh I'm you know I've never taught
a course before I've done thousands of
speeches but I've never
um spent an entire week with a group of
people and I realize when I think back I
I easily have 20 hours of curriculum in
my head about blue zones but chip is a
master at um
um I I would say packaging it and
delivering it and creating the right
environment and um creating the right
sort of cadence and I'm excited to learn
from him and he's going to co-facilitate
it yeah it's cool do you think of
yourself as a modern Elder uh
increasingly I can think of myself as an
elder I don't know how modern I am sadly
you're pretty hip and modern I hope that
I'm as you know as as happening as you
are in a key well I'd say like a couple
years younger than you so yeah well I I
think unconsciously I always kind of
emulate what you wore I remember I
showed up at a Google Zeitgeist uh
conference one once and you were wearing
the Lululemon suit jacket and and ABC
pants and I was wearing the same thing
we're both wearing black that one when I
try yeah because I showed up we did a
podcast with Charlie Ingle there yeah
that's right yeah speaking Yeah the
ultra America now I'm I'm going to that
event uh I think it's in like two weeks
that's a fantastic event any advice for
me you know I I can't sign out without
telling that this story I love to tell
but my ritual story
so
three years ago I wrote a cover story
for National Geographic on happiness
that's always been my professional goal
to have a cover story for National
Geographic and for the first time in
over a hundred years they put my name on
the cover
the written by Dan buettner and I had a
speech the day came out big Auditorium
and um
Unleashed everything I learned in this
cover story and showed the cover story
and afterwards there's a whole line of
people waiting to see me
uh to to talk about what I presumed was
the this cover story and I got down to
the light of people and they'd all
listened to me on the Rich Roll podcast
and they wanted to talk to me about the
podcast so um you know it's surprising
what a uh cultural Force you've become
in in um marshalling uh important
stories and without the hyperbole with
without the
um the
pandering I think to the gossip and the
celebrity and um you you you're so good
at distilling the soul and the spirit
and really the Zeitgeist of what's going
on
um in America and somehow
um getting Americans engaged with good
news and not just the bad news that
sells most newspapers
well I appreciate that my friend uh this
show is only uh successful as the
quality of the messages and the guests
that I have the privilege of hosting and
people wanted to talk to you about that
podcast because you delivered a
tremendous amount of value and that
value is a function of all of the hard
work over many years your curiosity and
your commitment honestly to service like
you're you're you're performing a
tremendous service to humankind this
book is just the latest you know
incarnation of that ongoing commitment
um and it's it's beyond laudable for me
you're the you're the North Star uh in
terms of like being a servant to
humankind and I only aspire to your
level of of commitment in that regard
and it's always an honor to talk to you
I consider you a friend and a mentor and
I'm super excited about this new book
and this new chapter and everything that
you have to share so I only
encourage you to get out there more and
talk more about these important ideas
because you have a lot to say and we
need to hear what you have to say so I
appreciate you coming in today sharing
the space with me and if there's
anything else that I can do
in service of of you and your mission I
am available to you 24 7. Thank you Rich
it's an honor cool so onwards until
podcast number five we'll see I think
you have a few things that are going to
be worth talking about soon so you
always have an open seat here thank you
rich thank you cheers peace plants
the American Kitchen
[Music]